greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by my bookie listen the NFL playoffs are
here it's time to get in on the action
with my bookie not only that you got
college basketball
you got you got you got college pro
basketball you got hockey you got the
UFC you got a lot of things going on it
really is the most wonderful time of the
year so do me a favor if you joined my
bookie now don't offer you a fifty
percent deposit bonus to make sure you
have a nice bankroll for bowl season use
promo code Church when you deposit to
activate the offer that's promo code
Church at my bookie you play you win you
get paid I also want to welcome on it
listen it's a new year with a new set of
rules and you're trying to make moves
and make things happen
honors the way they start without for
brain ok I'm traveling this week if you
don't think I have my immune tak with me
mushroom tech immune you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
everybody else got a mask on not me I'm
confident hey for those [ __ ] capsules
you're coughing my face not know what
happened why cuz that's on it for you
and alpha brain you want to get your
thoughts together you want to think
clear you want to have more focus alpha
brain is the way to go if it doesn't
work for you they don't even want the
product they just want they just don't
just give you the money back guarantee
but go to on it slash Church and get 10%
off delivered right to your
[ __ ] crib check that
[ __ ] melee it's always great
torture and Lyanna [ __ ] Thursday morning
how are you bad [ __ ] I got in
studio Carmen
Boogaloo Morales good thinking thing is
soldier who the [ __ ] don't worry about
none don't ask no questions first off I
hope your week is going great it's a
Thursday you know I'm saying I got a
head to [ __ ] in New York City to tape
some for my boy DB and could top Magoo
I'm right back the best thing about the
trip is I get to go to meet Ari and
Peter Lugar's and I'm excited cuz they
got the best [ __ ] steak in the
country and this will it be early so I
could
because I'm old you don't want to eat
meat late at night yeah you can't eat me
and then lay down no let's say you get a
heart attack then you jerk off and
that's it next thing you know they find
you in a rope around your neck and about
you trying to jerk off like the singer
from an excess create a different
narrative than what really happened you
just you just say stay too late
I was gonna say how does eating meat
make you put a rope around your neck
just makes you go crazy
can't be that kind of a con woman
what's that vaca gets in your brain man
yeah it's like with you as a young comic
I'm better at the store mm-hmm and along
the way I watched you like twice on
stage and then I found something that I
found out that you were a dog girl yeah
second indoor girl history second dog
girl history the [ __ ] Beyond at the
store when it's all changed
there was a time Mitzi would not hire a
male waiter but there was no male way
this guy's no no man no no she was like
opposite of calico Jack's that's going
on there now business-wise that there
was no food allowed she didn't want you
eating because you couldn't laugh mm-hmm
you just booze only so she took that hit
yeah it was booze and popcorn popcorn at
the tables that tasted like ass of
course keeping drinkin and then uh she
you know I don't think she'd have a dog
girl I don't think in her heart she
added like that to have a dog girl there
yeah in her mind I think she thought she
was the dog girl by the time I got this
she wasn't there every night so I don't
know but regardless of that yeah
somebody told me they ate you just went
in when they enhanced for the job
actually they asked me I didn't you were
[ __ ] Savage already yeah you didn't
really need to make the move but you
made the move which impress the [ __ ] out
of a guy like me because this whole
thing is about balls this whole business
it's it's you releasing all the [ __ ] you
are and going for it if you want it this
is how you gotta get it and it seems to
me that you wanted yeah don't panic
trying to get it all so you started all
playing for a couple big-name
you on the road so I want to let people
know who the [ __ ] common Morales is why
thank you that makes me feel real pretty
you know what I mean no no no no hey hey
hey relax all right
okay not that Norman Corwin Benjamin
Bratt film everything now we're fine
nobody knows nothing bad happened but
I'm just saying like that may feel
pretty like yeah you know you feels good
cause like that's one of the things that
motivates me is like some people like
its money the fame like mine was the
respect I wanted the best people to
think that I was good to you know
important is that to you it's the most
important that's what I'm seeing like
that's why I don't give a [ __ ] that I'm
not rich or that I'm not famous or
whatever cuz I'm never gonna not do this
and I'm never gonna not try and be good
at it so if that doesn't it doesn't
matter I don't give a [ __ ] you see
people who want to be rich and famous
and come on in fail I've closed those
people have you seen that they get in
those for the wrong reason mm-hm
instead of loving what the [ __ ] they're
doing and let the money come later the
most important thing about an artist you
releasing what the [ __ ] you want to do
it you don't want man I'm sick and
[ __ ] tired
I work that funeral Paula I want to make
shoes what I actually thought we were
recording at a funeral parlor because
they're right next door to 100 I see
this hearse pull out and I was like is
that where words this more talking every
podcast is a stick now so what cuz I
told you when when you came in that I'm
I just finished a year like what was
your process like for trying to get
people to bring you on the road cuz I
mean you've been doing it for a while I
grew up in a different time like I'm old
enough in comedy I grew up and that
wasn't a thing you had to just do it
yourself I knew guys that worked the
road I interrupt before so yeah sure
that was a horrific question because you
out a year I'm not looking for anybody
to bring you on I should be getting
ready to get on buses
and do feature work all around taxes
they don't know they don't go out future
you have to go out there now for two or
three years and bang it out okay buying
it so you going your future gigs
separate of the headliner are you just
going yeah you can just go ask them your
work okay so I know that you have to go
to clubs I'm not ready your club with me
and I take you you have to build a
relationship it's not that's why I
always say to you tip shut your [ __ ]
mouth don't ask for tea you know don't
grab nobody's ass don't grab no but
there's certain things you got to do
that's a protocol how do I know cuz I
did it but I failed at something that's
the number those days I was into drugs
hmm so drugs how is taking up so you
hung out with the kitchen staff a lot a
lot right right I feel long as you're 10
at that time I would sell 90 tickets mmm
78 tickets and I had a gig in Ontario on
Wednesday and Thursday they let me
headline two shows they were paying me
good money and finally The Improv the
rock yeah who I love
you know I've always loved it give me
ton of work over the years and they gave
me a hotel room because I had the radio
next day and I'll never forget tonight
what the Ontario checked into the hotel
room I tried to put the TV on and I
[ __ ] I had to do a while ago I didn't
know anybody for radio that night Here I
am I'm just finished getting the [ __ ]
Ontario I'm in the hotel room at night I
got radio at 6:00 no [ __ ] more well
it's 8 o'clock at night no crazing
cocaine by 9 o'clock I didn't know who
to call
so I got back in the car drove all the
way back to Hollywood got a grandma coke
and drove all the way back to the hotel
Ontario and I snorted coke till 5:00 and
blew off the radio and the improv repair
I mean [ __ ] furious pissed like that
was the last time they even took my
calls for like a year
oh wow [ __ ] like that type of [ __ ] I
used to do like that was mine that this
is 2006 mm-hmm 2005 when I was just out
of my rocker but that's the thing is
this cuz the comics like you guys that
[ __ ] everything up and then we end up
with no hotel room or no you know we
don't we don't let comics drink anymore
because they get all [ __ ] up I never
[ __ ] up a hotel room okay I never did
drinking at the bar you never drink up
to the shows no there was only two clubs
in the country boy I hung out at the bar
to Houston last but stop and the Miami
improv you know the clubs I went to like
I went to Miami and it was a [ __ ]
party every night mm-hmm
Coconut Grove and then I went to
Cleveland and they couldn't wait to get
rid of the customers my Cleveland's
improv that time like they had a line
pointing you to the [ __ ] door
get out yeah you are at the bar looking
for a package where we got a piece of
ass yeah
they would hush him out we're in Miami
they let you hang out there was a pool
table
you got them they had that whole
separate bar area they had this is the
old Miami this is this is 99 2000 2001
on the third floor in a mall across more
wet willies
you know what Wet Willie's almost frozen
and they have the one that's 140 proof
they won't call a cab yeah but the whole
mall got them I cannot describe like I
think I told it on a mondays podcast I
called Rogan on Saturday and we talked
about how it's taking about Chris
Chris something he owes their land a
punch line and he's also what's the
chubby kid from Mike & Molly
Billy gardels manager christabella yeah
christabella is a good good guy when I
first got here Christopher helped me a
lot
and I was just thinking about this the
other days I was [ __ ] putting it
plugs in my here getting ready gonna
shower I was saying my Christopher how I
own this the only Atlanta points line we
also managed whatever he would come out
here but his real wife was not landing
and kids and the whole thing so he owned
the punch line I don't know one specific
weekend where Rogan took me and Ari to
open from and Redman was a kid and tape
was Rogen's bodyguard and Eddie Bravo
would come along just to tag along so
they could do jujitsu at a gym so it was
like six of us on the road and looking
back at that this has to be 2003 2004
2002 and we did this video still on
there about me calling Duncan and
threatening him telling them he's a
devil worshiper have you ever seen that
clip on YouTube it's old it's me calling
Duncan and tell him to stop hanging out
with devil worshippers cuz they gonna
[ __ ] him his hands at that time it was
all of us going out everywhere and it
was me Rogan Ari Duncan red man red band
would just tape Phil so he and then they
were called the Joe show and it was Joe
Rogan showing it was us on the road
every weekend but anyway to get back to
the point I still love being outside
that parking lot and making that tape of
the red banner hanging up and laughing
my ass off that was up on stage that
night and I was talking about [ __ ] or
sucking or something hmm and some lady
with a Southern drawl I said who the
[ __ ] would [ __ ] you huh and Rogan was
back there and he heard it made a joke
about it but at that moment in the
shower it came to me that that was as
good as it was being
like those times yeah we were crazy like
I still remember haters gonna let Lana
points on it because it was an hour from
the airport and we would be used to go
fly on Monday mornings that that was the
first couple of times Rogan took those
sunday shows and Monday morning traffic
with a flight length delayed you
wouldn't land at LAX till 6:00 at night
and that's why I said no more Sundays oh
you don't do Sundays no no I don't fly
on Monday why because it's the busiest
day of the week I don't want to be
caught in that there's no need for it
and I for years I played to sunday
audiences who hated me
[Laughter]
yeah Sunday you're miserable you wake up
your girlfriend cause you you she's
gonna parents asked for cookout in here
you are a bum [ __ ] [ __ ] in a motel 6
that's the TV don't work it smells like
curry in the hallways who books that can
i [ __ ] no you know these are the gig you
take as you're developing over the years
sure you know you don't know till you
get there I can't imagine now in the
world of what says should we stay at
people's houses
Airbnb if I was a family club I didn't
B&B comics well there's a difference you
can at least get a whole apartment
putting me in a room with so I had
someone else's house don't put you to
Roomba somebody else yeah I mean we used
to have to sometimes stay with like the
waitstaff or I can't tell you how many
times I've slept in in the extra room
where the manager lives like and it's
like you know you can't even give us a
little our own box you can't give us a
little box or a shitty hotel I'd even
take the curry hotel you're talking
about yeah the motel I'd rather take
that it's it's pretty much $60
everywhere in the country for a motel 6
and I'd rather have that than like have
to stay it's somebody else's house yeah
that creeps me out like I'm a guy I just
I would never that I think I would sleep
in my car instead
well that's that's part of this whole
[ __ ] thing
is that how much you sacrifice you know
I think when you own
I love you free rephrase them the right
way or whatever somebody takes you on
the road when they see something in you
like that girl started taking you on the
road I forget her name
the real funny blonde Oh Maria Maria
said she saw you one night don't you was
something different in front of it and
she he's a comic yeah she knows how you
are audience is gonna react to you I
know what my audience of people will
come in I'm gonna react that I already
know you have some of the best audience
members to ya there because would
sincere yeah they listen to podcast
they're very respectful they understand
the you're on Akali they've heard what
we go through in the process they apply
it the principles that we use to their
own lives as [ __ ] whatever they are
artists or graphic designers architects
that takes a certain discipline you know
I love when comics come on here and have
stories especially a [ __ ] woman
especially a Latin woman who's doing
comedy let's pretend we just erased the
Latin woman you're just a comedian you
just one of us you just have a dick but
you tie it up talk it I don't tie it up
and I tell any woman leave a small dick
I tell any woman who comes on the box
it's really like a five inch clip yeah I
mean just like a really long clip I
don't mean he ever smack a guy on the
face we click so fun no it's weird how I
respectable women comics a lot because I
know what the [ __ ] they go through like
I was here 20 years ago when there was a
guy that hung up a van and these girls
were hanging out with him and there were
female cop those girls are long time cuz
it was a party atmosphere sure like it
was a party atmosphere that was really
supposed to be a comedic atmosphere but
so I've seen people come and go
and your story like you're on your way I
always like to pluck people and put them
on the podcast when they're on their way
when you you could see that not today it
may not be in five years but it may be
in the seven years or it could be ranked
on anyway or it could be the morning
yeah you just have all the tools for
that to happen which is good you know
I'm saying that's a great thing so in
the world to discover who the [ __ ]
Carmen Morales without television just
meaning it like their own [ __ ] clip I
don't want to see why not it'd be funny
it's disgusting it's funny when your
curse oh but it's fine for you guys to
slap a [ __ ] with your dick
I can't slap a guy with my clip why not
I haven't slept a woman with my dick and
that's gotta be thirty years so what you
still did it but that was a long time
ago you can't hold it against me there's
no statute limitations about I'm not
holding it against you I'm just saying I
can do the same [ __ ] thing it's a
woman's world now my friend Rick don't
wanna pop it out of them on the face of
it then put it back in their mouth
[ __ ] yum yum like a little like a
little golf swing and I've never smacked
a girl in the faith that come on they're
focused on the deck you can see every
it's like from that last dick thing
gonna suck
and once they close their eyes it's all
timing you take it out I don't even know
what's happening don't even know it's
happened it's totally a mic sucking some
often you just [ __ ] whip them in the
face right here what's going on they
start looking around you put it writing
them up and they go right back into
rhythm and then they start humming - so
I was like a nice little vibration
because they're trying to yell at you
but there's a dick in there then you ask
me like Lahey the face [ __ ] with that
steer of death don't you yes so why
can't I do that we might clip what's
wrong with it except my gym it up their
nose too sometimes just to be funny
because people gonna contact the air one
picture the equipment how long again
where'd you start Orlando Orlando
Florida is that what you're from
originally
mm-hmm Wow one of the few people that
are actually born there lot of [ __ ] I
did not know Al and though it was filled
with that many [ __ ] Puerto Ricans I'm
not Porto Rican right there is a ton of
them there's a ton there I did not know
that years ago I played maybe think
about the poor because this time don't
you go and oh that's what they keep how
far is Tampa from Orlando yeah like an
hour yes so I did tampa orlando for the
Spanish woman my son was a boxer and she
had with the Camacho's I don't know
where she would book rooms yeah I did a
couple of those rooms she tried booking
rooms that was one of the saddest nights
of my life
[Laughter]
wait tell me what happened what are we
going this was the Facebook this was the
myspace days and I was writing the blog
I don't know what she was thinking she
she is snip on MySpace and she very nice
lady real attractive mm-hmm attractive
older you know well she was younger than
me at the time but whatever she asked me
if I wanted to come that she was a
promoter and what was my feet and I
asked her for like a low number how much
well would you feed back then I think I
asked of the 750 issue for each so how
many shows one show just one show each
night either way okay in a plane ticket
the hotel room to pick me up at the
airport
hmm she was like no problem okay so I
flied down there the first night we do
tons of [ __ ] radio Friday morning
Spanish yeah act why this is a long
[ __ ] time
you know what we got told I mean it was
horrible it was horrible
I did a toddler radio and the first
night we got about a hundred people and
Orlando baby then the next I had to go
to Tampa and I remember going to the
hotel and walking around I couldn't
believe how many [ __ ] New Yorkers oh
yeah New York in Ohio if they all go
there oh my god mm-hmm everything is New
York city-based
mm-hmm I'm walking down the blue New
York Pizza York and they really are from
New York and they really all they say
they are yeah I mean the pizzas
everything in Tampa those people are
never ever walking and seeing a yellow
and blue umbrella
and gone and my [ __ ] pollution in
this separate hot dogs in Tampa oh yeah
I walked up to the guy and I go how you
doing these really sad brats as I get
i'm a retired fireman I moved down here
after I retired my soul and I saw hot
dogs and he had the onions the bun yeah
and the ears you know what the trick is
is they boil them and he put a little
bit of red wine vinegar in the water and
that's what makes them all extra sub
ready that's what it is so delicious
guy told me those that's what the
Yankees have their spring training
spring training so it's like the whole
everybody's from New York now I did not
know it so we get the Tampa and it's
tonight somebody's fighting in the USA
I know you know it was for sure the guy
we had on years ago that he showed up on
a Monday night and we had somebody else
there he fought Anderson Silva beat him
up he's from Ohio and this is silver
beat him up two times he was the world
champion this is how long ago was he was
fighting somebody else we must have had
16 people at that show oh well you still
paid she still pay yeah and she came up
to me
this is one of the hardest things I ever
had to do in my life because by that
time I had a dit with those type of
molars yeah the night of the show they
pour you're selling on let me holla at
you for a second
oh that's always when you know if think
about it if I offer you a job Joey I'm
gonna be a graphic designer you're gonna
get 40 hours every week at $30 an hour
and every week I pull you aside and go
hey man though you work 40 hours but I'm
only gonna pay you for 20 you know what
it's except it's not acceptable it's not
acceptable I don't know no it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] ridiculous and they're all
making money like I worked what led into
this situation not to let anybody a
Carmen nor Lee the judge me in a wrong
way was I got involved for three years
with just bad promoters like I went from
one to another it's it's the luck of the
draw entirely war [ __ ] at that point
we need money and we want to do big
venues and we want to get better so when
you dedicate yourself to the road Rich
Franklin Rich Franklin
so Rich Franklin was fighting but to
lead up to this I got involved with the
Latino Knights of comedy mm-hmm he was
he says he was the promoter of Earth
Wind and Fire he had this long resume
call you on the phone and give you any
abilities I took three beatings from it
three beats the first one was I
understood let me holler at you
listen I can't give you the 500 I
promised you I'm only gonna be able to
give you 300 but I brought you a little
bag of reefer just to let you know I'm
in your corner
you know and after a while you get
people think of people doing that to you
every week then the second time I worked
for him at some point it's like you're
insulting my intelligence at this point
oh my god then the second time I work
for him there was something else I was
[ __ ] up he did something with the
plane tickets so we had to take a bus
and it was all night long and then the
time I work for him I got three-quarters
of the money but at 3:00 in the morning
my door was knocking he had ran out on
the tab on the radio station the police
are there manager of the venue and had
people and that's what I said I can't
work for anybody
yeah they're not getting their money how
about what makes you think they're ever
he's never gonna give you your [ __ ]
money and then I had this white dude out
of a like some part of Texas but every
time I work there
there was always a story mm-hmm and I
mix it up with other work like you know
what it's too late to cancel that on me
yeah because yeah he would always call
you a week before the run had switch the
gig from Friday to Saturday you did what
there's a barbeque on Friday so
nobody'll come to the comedy show you
know a week before the [ __ ] show
there was one of those guys so I went
through all this [ __ ] mm-hmm this is the
[ __ ] that you have to go through in
order to get through to people to pay
you in clubs you have to work those
shitty rooms for a long [ __ ] I mean
there are ways to not have to do that if
you grow up in a scene like like Miami
and or like like a scene that has an a
club a lot of times they don't go
through those and a lot of those comics
don't end up being good because of it
because they you when you're battling
you know people wanting to watch the the
MMA fighter wanting to you know and when
you're interrupting people's seafood
dinner that they didn't know a [ __ ]
comedy show is about to happen once you
figure out how to still make that work
then you're completely and utterly
unstoppable because you've gone through
everything what do you think you think
four people is gonna stop me from
performing incredibly well no let me
show you how I can dazzle four
[ __ ] who are completely
uninterested what time you usually go up
at the store now I'm I do all the
opening set so it's super early so I
bite the bullet all the time what do you
think of those opening spots there look
here's the thing Joey I'm charming his
[ __ ] okay and people like that so it's
not that bad it's not that bad
I also don't hate people I can
everybody does like it's supposed to be
cool as a comedian to hate people I
don't hate people I mean I hate people
but hate things that people do but
they're all just I mean we're all just
[ __ ] trying right until we're dead
yeah no no this is this is what you do I
mean there's no giving up once you join
the family I can't see on Facebook in
ten years selling real estate doesn't
work well with an HR department I've
seen a lot of that lately in it and it's
saddened me and it gives me a chance to
bat myself on the back because I stuck
with something mm-hmm you know there's a
lot of things that motivate me that I
can't talk about public says people get
their feelings hurt you know it's like
the ship I like that I couldn't do as a
comic but that's my decisions what do
you mean like what what can't you do you
can do anything that's what's the what's
why it's the greatest art form right I
don't mean like that
oh I guess things I wouldn't do anymore
because of how I like to work things
okay I couldn't see myself at that
position right now after all the work I
put in so when I see those guys in that
position I kind of Pat myself on the
show but for sticking with it sure
there's a lot of people right now that
were funny and I am the back home and
they're not doing what they love because
they gave up on this place to have
excuses they point their fingers at you
and other comics and say we're gay or
whatever the [ __ ] the only way to make
it that way
dude yeah yeah how will this suckers big
443 million dollar deal yeah whatever
you know it's but not really see that
that's what that's what I admire about
you that you have been doing comedy for
12 years and one day you walk into the
Comedy Store and accept a job as a dog
girl whatever the [ __ ] you want it was
strange
what was strange to me about that is
everybody else's reactions to it cuz it
was like some people like I can't
believe you took that job
like you're above that job or and some
people were like I don't know if that's
a good move like you worked the road and
stuff like everybody was just like
feeling all this apprehension for me and
I was like what yeah I don't know but if
it doesn't work out then it just doesn't
work out I think who are you working the
road yeah I mean that was my only
stipulation cuz they they asked me um
and they told me it was like the
quickest way for me to kind of get
through that whole passing system and I
said well as long as I was like white
the only way I make money is through
staying up I don't have a job or
anything like that so as long as this
doesn't stop me from working the road at
all then it's fine and they've been
really cool like I was just gone for
almost two months and they were good
they were cool and then I came back for
two weeks and then was gone again like
they're awesome I mean they mean they
know and they were they're incredible
people too like they also believe in me
too like and and I am very honest with
them I'm like I'm not I'm not gonna try
to [ __ ] you over when I'm here I'll do
my job it's a very very positive place
it's really great really become a very
very no arguing no more hassles nobody
really gets along with each other nobody
runs the clock industry hours no more
yes become well except for Chappelle but
that's fine no that was he there last
night that he stay as I was walking out
yes you went up last night did he yeah
he went up a couple like a month ago and
was there till like 5:00 in the morning
Wow but then what they also expect that
from him too you know what I mean it's
also about mashapaug Dave Chappelle
exactly and he's not doing it every
night no which would be yeah yeah that
must be frustrating because I joy was
great and I got to do a Senate the open
mic or friends and family this week and
he didn't he did I think he did less
than 15 minutes but I had never like
seen anything get bumped or I guess it's
not even really a bump it was just a
drop in from like Todd Barry came and
did the room it was cool just after
seeing like 23 minutes Seth to see like
a guy who's a professional going and
like
how he can work the same audience and
how they were quiet before another
laughing it was if it was I went up a
lot later was fun
it's really weird to see when somebody
figures out the puzzle mm-hmm it's a
beautiful thing to see when there's ten
comics and all ten comics and an open
mic eight of them eat it yeah I to love
do okay they got a couple s and then a
guy that's been doing comedy 15 20 years
walks up there and just levels
derivative I love doing that is I know
that sounds so braggadocious but I love
that I love when it's just a string of
nothings just passing the baton akak and
then you just watch and just go oh you
guys just haven't been [ __ ] right
you're watching it's comedy dig a hole
yeah and you just avoid all those
landline I'm just gonna avoid those
landmines and I'm gonna attack them this
way and you level them and you come off
the stage and they look at you and they
go what they touch you a Jesus like what
the [ __ ] I do but what's even funnier is
when you do that and you go up and
you're like oh I'll got this and you go
up there and then you eat a bit affect
dick to that humbling experience the
exact opposite that happens where you're
like come by even a comic do I even do
this right you know I started eating a
dick last night in the main room in the
original room I had him but I really did
mm-hmm
but none of that stuff bothers me at the
Comedy Store right like it doesn't
affect me it's just a cost of doing
business
mm-hmm when I go to a county store even
at this level now and I still need a bag
of dick like last night I closed with an
old joke that means I'm dying
that means I'm dying that means that
doesn't mean I'm dying it means that you
write everything there I got so high I
forgot my material which happens yeah go
to the vault I get back into the main
room the [ __ ] Geno's back there with
speed wheesh and right away he gives me
a blunt and I smoke it nobody wants to
smoke
I smoked the whole thing by myself by
the time I got up I forgot everything I
tried I tried new [ __ ] mm I wanted to
try some new [ __ ] but it's just not
clicking they don't see me as a dad the
audience does not see me as a dad why
it's all that quality I can sell uncle
uh-huh but I can't sell the dead they
laugh at the jokes but then they go back
uncle Joey jokes they they go it it's
very weird well you should remind them
as sometimes uncle's or dad's too
[ __ ] so I've been trying there's
no material out just you know hey listen
you got to change it up constantly you
have to evolve as a human as a comic as
an electrician as an artist as a [ __ ]
painter you just can't keep painting
dicks or 5-inch quits after a couple
weeks of these comin coming up the
Japanese artists it at the 50 views of
Mount Fuji what did he do he it was like
he did 50 set different views of the
same mountain and all the what but I get
wait I get worse you can't be annoyed
especially at the store every time you
show up you have to show up with a
different gun I do feel that way like it
I don't you okay I have to do a
different set every time I go yeah you
gotta show up with 20 weapons like
generally and there's some lights I just
don't care I'm just so happy to be there
like by the time I got to the original
room last night
it was like I had done a [ __ ] in a
heroin yeah I was very not last that was
none know what my pace was very slow man
I'd bang him but it was very much slow
but in your written in the main room I
had to come on the river mm-hmm I had to
come out swinging in the main room for
my life it's just a different feeling
I'm swinging in the main along and the
main room I came out swinging from my
life okay that's how I feel on the first
round in the original room I just sat
back in the pocket and smack the
horrible
yeah if you were gonna ask me that
question before I would have reversed it
I thought you were always a lot more
aggressive in the original room but last
night I went up last in the manual ah so
with a positioning way you're at all
these things matter I didn't know they
told me stellar show yeah they told me
they were going up at 8:45 when I got
that they said no that was his schedule
so if I was where I was supposed to stay
my my energy would have been different
where I went as the closer of the show I
had to go out there as an animal that's
the mindset so this didn't I didn't
write this this is the years of doing it
mm-hmm
this is years of going through the
[ __ ] process yeah you don't want this
show to end like as a bummer and if they
just saw an incredibly other thing to is
different if it's a bunch of people
eating dicks but this is the main room
of the Comedy Store you know there's a
ton of great comedians that just went up
if you have to go at the end you know
you have you have to dazzle them you
can't just go up there be like so uh
Widow Sibel me like you have to [ __ ]
close the show but you also have to
think of who you are what you are
I don't ever want you to forget who you
are because everybody else is having a
bad set
see you're gonna go up dead try to be
learning you learn it I've always gotten
up there for years I went up there with
that to at the store I was never
competitive I was just like to do or die
situation because I thought yeah yeah
disarray I never knew if it was gonna be
my last spot oh I wonder when I got to
the store they told me Mitzi has the
place wired she is every set at home she
watches everything and [ __ ] the first
weekend I'm there she put me in the
original when the Maine woman showed up
I saw that Mondays you can hang and I'm
like time in the main room Saturday
night and then I jumped on her and said
hello ever want to go back in there yeah
let me just do a little more spots on
people stay friends she was like oh no
I'm putting you back in there next week
and that went on for a year yeah I made
money because in those days no spots
would pay $450
mm-hmm but at the same time it was 20
minutes of horror like if you see it and
all these scary movies you have no idea
yeah
you haven't know it was 20 minutes of
horror I'll take a killer clown any day
at 12:20 okay when there's about 84
people yeah that type of [ __ ] but when
it just starts getting real depressing
yeah you know that's where you start
from that's just that's the whole thing
but again that's as good as it gets the
reason why why I go into the original
room and lay it out like that is because
I just woke up one day or somebody took
me out on the road it was all that [ __ ]
I chiseled off like I have these shows
and Buffalo can I know they're gonna be
buck wild and I'm just dabbing with the
idea of really and just throw them out
there to the walls coming from Canada I
want to seem throw bottles out of this
[ __ ] ideas don't throw bottles at me
please oh please
I just I'm dabbing what if I don't know
be sure Jesus Christ
this girl's supposed to be featuring for
me up there but some happens I'm not to
call you and throw you to the wolves
okay in Buffalo just to see why I got
Jones it's gotta learn to swim somewhere
is either gonna drown or having a
glimpse at it this year when I did I did
a show when the knockout of the year was
happening like right behind me but it's
uh it's crazy how the audience really
does matter like I noticed that because
I just did the main room a week or two
ago and then I did the original room the
other night but the main room was more
comedy fans like pod they were podcast
people they were comedy fans and the
original room was like people who go to
the open mic it was kind of it was it it
was interesting how the art like some of
the same material they reacted to
differently because of what kind of
audience they were that way you don't
[ __ ] audiences they're all the same
they're always saying don't start
categorize but that's what I was talking
about about your fans not so much that
they appreciate
comedy but also that they're good
laugher like whenever people like and
I'll ask people in line and stuff like
that who are you here to see and when
they're there for you that room is just
vibrates their stone the stone them
excited you know I'm excited you know I
start sending signals out about five
o'clock I start sending signals out to
the troops let them know [ __ ] I hope
you're getting ready cuz I am I really
went to the gym I just ordered salmon I
roll the joint I'm gonna go downstairs
after room service and smoke a [ __ ]
Dube do you realize how cool that would
be if other people could get that as
their jobs if like people could get that
excited about them like you never see
like a bunch of people like just outside
of a surgeon's office like dude I can't
wait till you [ __ ] cope but just cut
open my chest just get real jazzed about
it I think people would do their jobs
better if they went they had more
cheerleaders like if they had more
actual fans
I think people started off liking their
job everybody starts off liking your job
you know especially if you're part of
college and you went for that specialize
everybody starts you know we love comedy
yeah we love copy how do you think
that's one of the things that people are
attracted us by is that when we love the
thing so much we love comedy yeah what
makes comedy hard answer me any of you
what makes comedy hard us we make it
hard know the business side the business
side yeah but that's the ice part where
were on stick all this was about
what's that stolen comedy mm-hmm this is
all this about when you first get up on
stage do you lose at the store yesterday
and I looked at him and I'm like I still
remember him blowing up Def Jam off an
emcee spot yeah getting a standing
ovation and that'd be over 20 years ago
mm-hmm when he was hosting Def Jam he
took it from Martin for a while Martin
Lawrence
something I don't know what the deal was
I saw him you understand innovation as
an MC and on HP [ __ ] oh well if he
was that good then how deadly and
calculated is he today that was pure
energy off an MC spot that was always my
dream that's the reason why when I went
to the store see a little secret know
how people know is I had already become
a regular and I was already hosting on
Sunday nights but they said they needed
a doorman on Sunday nights so I went the
mid side omits it how about I work the
door from 7:00 to 10:00 and then at
10:00 I host and while I do my 15
minutes I have somebody worked at law
and then when I got off stage in between
sets I just have somebody who watch the
back door she was done but she was never
there on Sundays so i scammed it out you
have to do this to people because at
that time the store had this overflow of
comics it doesn't have anymore
but you don't see that at all anymore
but there was a time when there was an
overflow of comics that would go up to
the mingle on any given night especially
if the ruling I thought that Mitzi was
gonna be up there during the week show a
lot of old-time comics and comics would
show up there like those hallways that
you see now that's all people well I got
to the store that was all comics waiting
for Mitzi to come up there so they could
tormentor Mitzi we love you can we get
your soda so there was all those people
up there there were haters yeah that's
so gross so what they would do is in
those days at 12 o'clock somebody would
come out and they would put a list out
and those first 20 people would sign up
and those were regulars who didn't get
spots
sure would be a bunch of regulars who
didn't get spots so what I would do is
like the reason why they weren't getting
spots is because they just didn't cut it
yeah I knew this from the grapevine yeah
this kind of mom too much
this guy bombing from the mid sea you
hear about it you know yeah so you saw
that list I would see the list and go oh
this is like six bombs in a row and
there's a hundred people in there yeah
can't take it
yeah I didn't do this for myself for
personal reasons I did this so that
could be a longer show right so they
didn't walk everybody these comics that
one which sign up the first twenty what
comics that were disgruntled they were
pissed off they were hangry they were
jealous cuz I don't blame them I don't
have enough man than anybody I would
never want to be in that position myself
at that position I had nothing at the
little years I had nothing but I wasn't
as disgruntled as they were rightly said
on Sunday they had hosted spot at ten
o'clock that was a cool [ __ ] spot to
have okay so it would be the open mic
friends and neighbors within the program
friends a family and then they would
have one they would slip a few regular
door people in there sure and then I
would come up at ten and do ten minutes
so what I would do on Sunday nights was
I would pace it out the first Sunday I
would call Paul Mooney for Paul Mooney
I'm hosting that I Pro if you're there
at 10:15 I'll put you on you could do
how much time you want to do you yeah I
got you a neat sale hey brother I'll be
down and he get this sure enough ten
o'clock I'd [ __ ] get offstage to Paul
Mooney
so I can leave mm-hmm so I would [ __ ]
I would get up go outside get down virus
and go done is the list you want to host
the rest of it and the next day I would
find out that more than an hour so by
that time it's morning by the time when
he got off they lost 40 people and those
guys
get on stage but those 20 comments would
be back they're [ __ ] furious furious
and I would never say it was me I would
always go what do I'm gonna do stop home
we can going on stage yeah so I had a
list I had Mooney Eddie Griffin mmm
Rogan mmm-hmm dice Oh
so I would rotate them so every Sunday I
would call them and say hey I know
you're interested in doing an hour come
on down do your house probably get out
stage at 10:10 and I did get there and I
get on stage and bring him up and I give
dombarris the paperwork and I go buy a
[ __ ] grandma blow in the bathroom we
do it wait for [ __ ] the Gothic
dressed up by Jesus tries to tell it
mm-hmm that he used to hate Jewish
people so he used to put his finger in
there his nose and then he locked
himself in the men's bathroom and they
kicked the door down together my Rob
Robert at Avaya every Sunday night I'd
out with lunatics up there
he's still there no he's done yes he is
he wears a green jacket yes he goes
onstage and he talks about yeah like
though he looks old and crazy I'm
certain it just as crazy as he did when
you saw he's holy
he accused me of lighting him on fire
one night I was in Miami and I got a
call from something you might I was
thinking about it I talked about it
because it was a fire bomb what happened
was he would lock himself in the men's
bathroom right by the windows
now you don't know how many times there
was comics that actually put mirrors
there was one comic in particularly oh
man oh man sure sure in fact I just saw
him on Facebook he's not a comic no more
he had a mirror in that bathroom and you
could see girls piss and [ __ ] oh yeah do
it slow oh yeah there was some stairs
and look at the mirror oh wow this guy
was a filthy animal that's why he's not
a comic no more but we would always sit
there and talk
[ __ ] mm-hmm in those days what's his
name
the guy that hosted like the dingdong
show yeah
dr. Sam Barris would torment robber the
provider they would go at it so fast
that Robert a provider would lock
himself in the men's bathroom for hours
they'd have to bang on it they still go
at it no no is he causing a racist
pedophile yes so late this this is real
so what now I'm sitting and I'm like why
doesn't somebody just light a fire and
throw it into the window like toilet
paper put gasoline on it i watch the
burning bed once too many times and
throw it in there well [ __ ] do you
know I'm out of town a month later
somebody threw a toilet paper roll now
fire and he couldn't turn it off in the
toilet but something happened in the
men's bathroom why I got a call on a
Monday that you set him on fire no I'm
in Miami
it wasn't me it was so much drama with
him on Sunday nights like it was
craziness I used to be there I think I
hosted three years I'm so good you did
not do that for three years I said then
every Sunday oh hang it out with
gorillas Dawg but I had to be there what
working the door okay from 7:00 to 10:00
so I would hear all the chitter chatter
and all the [ __ ] and all the how
come I can't go up number three I
deserve it
where's Mitzi when is Mitch he coming
down when Mitch he comes down him I'm
gonna straighten this problem I
everybody had a story with Lindsay
everybody had a [ __ ] story right I
just got to the point where I would tell
people listen on the lady of [ __ ]
stores yeah that was driving on Laurel
Canyon I told but this creepy guy that
I'll put odds down that if I look that
guy up he molested someone somebody
somewhere along the line he was bald he
wear a long jacket and he come up dad
tell you about all the gays they do this
is before the internet I would never
look him up he dropped names and I let
him go for about an hour that but I look
under no yeah but you're not doing any
spots here and he would just crack you
were here
he would walk away I've done that to a
few people because he was so annoying on
Sunday nights don't I will get tormented
yeah of course there and so you're the
early only peer what you're wearing the
logo so they they just feel no I I would
wear my own clothes but they would still
unload all their [ __ ] I'm gonna load
this [ __ ] on me that was every week then
that other guy started bothering me
though they said I killed the old no you
killed one too you set one on fire man
they're really forgiving it the store
this guy was a [ __ ] old guy that was
crazy
he would he was crazy and he had his
moments of being nice but then by the
end of the night the medication would
wear off and always end up with him
marching off throwing a bottle at the
wall and saying a bunch of [ __ ]
this was mental health at its finest I
mean we've seen mental health this is
this is when you go to an open mic in a
small town like when you first start out
like I want like when I started in
Denver mm-hmm I was just talking about
the guy that was what's his name the man
of a thousand voices yeah and he only
heard to everybody that yeah he had one
shitty voice all the day he had his tape
recorder mm-hmm and he was hitting this
tape recording guy bombed and he was
hitting his tape recorder and he [ __ ]
kept selling I go what's the matter he
goes this thing doesn't pick up -
laughter oh I mean when you're that
delusional and then I moved to Seattle
and you should have seen the open mic is
up there on the Monday night if there
was 16 open Mica's mm-hmm sick son could
legally be declared and I not do a
little I know one who killed himself in
that crew for sure another one who
wanted to kill herself for sure that was
what I learned that there was a problem
in our community
oh yeah and I started doubting who I was
why because this is what you go through
is economic
when you read it cuz I got thrown out of
Denver so what the Seattle
when I got the Seattle Monday nights
were Josh wolf okay Brody Stevens tame
them a new Mitch Hedberg charred hogan
all these comics but there was just one
blonde coming that will come up every
week with a handcuffed up and he would
just go up there and fight for his life
and come off and explain the situation
to you I mean I saw some [ __ ] when I was
yet I was working on open mic one night
when a comic walk till he was over this
side I like a what's up [ __ ] man get
me a town my wife just stabbed me right
[Laughter]
[ __ ] wrapped himself up keep
things interesting the problem is
there's no open mic here like that
because the stakes are different mm-hmm
again this is why I do not like this
place because the stakes are different
then open mic in Houston an open mic on
Orlando all Michael Syracuse an open mic
in Michigan is a completely different
open mic then you're gonna see them all
say that's Sara okay Los Angeles's is a
complete different it's a different
dream mm-hmm it's a different thing it's
a different you stop talking to people
and you see that you're not really in
love with comedy you're a love with the
dream of being a star you think by
coming down here three times a week this
is gonna save you and change your life
it's a whole lifestyle that you have to
adhere to so I've seen him come and go
especially at the store guys that had
way more talent guys that wrote you
could tell that they wrote yeah they
just the pressures of LA was just too
much the ups and downs or whatever
that's because they never
had the foundation that foundation of
not caring see well I do an open mic in
Michigan I'm not worried about the guy
from AP ambien in the audience yeah well
I don't have an open mic in Michigan the
first two years nobody talks to you
about a headshot you're taking pictures
of your license and you know the first
two years you're thinking your emphasis
is don't stand up right it's not about
what if this that's what I don't like
about how I mm-hmm because the the
stakes are different you know when you
talk to people in San Francisco they
can't wait to come to Iowa because the
stakes are different but they have to
stay in their hometown and build the
foundation I tell that to people other
hand the foundation you know to be safe
this sixth day is just to be safe just
to be safe at all angles so you I want
you to come back and tell me about when
you slept in your car when you get to
the hotel all the rules would check that
when you had a share room but the
headliner you'd lost a leg in Vietnam so
the whole night you had to stare at his
legs hanging on the wall you know you
have no idea yeah it's not the stage
part it's the living through that daily
struggle that's what builds you up
that's what makes other comics relate to
you know by the time you get here
nothing could really bother hmm why do
you wanna sit here till 12:30 all right
I've heard I've done worse yeah I'm at a
sit outside a hotel overnight the wait
to check in at 3:00 and you in there at
301 how you doing
stinkfly
Subway sandwich fast food a flatulence
rolling roaches like you just roll with
roaches that are [ __ ] in your car
yeah trying to make yeah you got
changing your [ __ ] knew that I had a
box of change I'll never forget that
change box I was hidden under the front
seat mm-hmm and that was like going
there
like I didn't know how much exact was in
there had to be like $18 like I store my
believing Boulder for the road the first
time I had two licenses like I thought
I'd lost my license and I got another
one
mmm I'd never forget filling up the car
and Tom the guy didn't have no cash is
my license I'll be back in five minutes
and not paying probably got a warning
Boulder for $20 but it's amazing well
that's the difference that people don't
see mm-hmm you know before bill burr was
bill burr you had to get booed to death
in Boston thousands of millions of
people saw that video Philadelphia by
that time yet Philadelphia that time
bill brought be doing comedy 15 20 years
yeah and you still getting booed at
that's what people don't realize I've
noticed well that's why it doesn't make
sense for me when the young ones they're
like two years in and they want to move
here and I'm like why would you want all
this additional pressure like it doesn't
make any sense you should go and fall in
love with it for real and then come here
and endure this because if you're not if
you come out here when you're half assed
into it I would do this why would I am
the times living well in 99 I had no
brakes on my car I didn't know I've done
that do a 90 with no brakes no insurance
and don't rent registration and I'm
[ __ ] breaking here in the metal
cheering oh my god you feather the
ebrake featherly break what is this come
on no I and that car got towed with
everything I all did it headshot
boxes well mine was stolen I had mine
stolen when I was living out of my car
my car got stolen way that way known in
Florida I was in Florida I was just
coming back from being on the road so
like and at the time I had like $10,000
with a camera equipment ID I like
started a curling camera equipment over
the years to because then I was taking
pictures of people and [ __ ] so I would
just do people's headshots I was that
was another way I would make extra money
on the road I was oh
into a side skin like I used to sell
weed I used to sell drugs whatever
anything I could do that so I didn't
have to stop doing stand-up
everything else was always just like a
symptom of me being able to have enough
money that I could keep doing stand-up
and then I came back and my car got
stolen they stole it to like commit a
bunch of crimes in and then so I lost
all my [ __ ] all my clothes in there all
my toiletries I had a bite I had to buy
a new toothbrush what are you going to
stand them family what made you fall in
love with the art I was a fan of it when
I was a little kid like the first one
Bill Cosby himself and like Gallagher
was I don't remember which which one it
was the one when there is a big couch at
the end where he jumps on the couch and
he pulls all this stuff everything has
everybody has in their couch or
something like that and then Robin
Williams night at the Roxy so then I
just used to like you know how like a
little like a lot of times little kids
will want to watch frozen over and over
and over again I just used to do that
but with stand-up specials and what made
you to finally decide to take the plunge
did you tell your mom dad no I mean I
try I try to keep it from me on stage 20
to 22 and you know at that point when
you got our stage this is what you
wanted to do well I didn't I guess I
didn't know at first because I used to
do I would did debate when I was in high
school I was a theater kid I used to
sing in choirs and [ __ ] so I was in
front of people but I wasn't doing the
thing that I wanted to do which was the
hardest one
so just scared of it and then even Mike
I used to sell timeshare over the phone
and even like my boss at that job was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing here
like you feel like you should be doing
something else and her next door
neighbor was engaged to a comedian and I
didn't know you could just be a comedian
I didn't know you could just do it so I
was just I just thought you like they
handpick you because you were this
brilliant talented thing and that was it
you just had to get discovered I didn't
know they were like they were poor
comedians and then I was like a like a
beer I could be a poor comedian so then
I started I started going to open mics I
did that bit classic
comedian deal where I was like if I go
up if I get any laughs I'll come back
and do it and I didn't write anything
beforehand it was all completely
improvised I just [ __ ] I made up a
whole story when I was on stage and I
got a laugh so I came I came back did
you tell your mom and dad you were doing
it at this point no I didn't tell him
for that for a while what they think
when you first told well I mean my dad
told me he would never support me if I
went into the arts but he told me that
when I was a kid so I didn't really
really care what he thought but my mom
was always like she was always
supportive what did your dad want you to
be he wanted me to be a UH I think an
accountant
did you ever sisters and brothers you
have a half-sister okay so he wanted you
to be in the cabin why is he a [ __ ]
accountant no he is an eighth grade he's
eight he went to school up to eighth
grade and then stopped going to school
where we started in Cuba and then with
you what he finished it in Jersey he's a
New Jersey Cuban guy from Union City is
he so we know each other
maybe he's probably like 10 years 10 or
15 years only six yeah he's probably
like 10 years older than really or maybe
no maybe like six or seven yeah we know
each other yeah maybe so he quit going
to school in the 8th grade to get a job
like that yeah I was the upbringing he
loved you but he was strict as [ __ ] and
insane yeah he's like he's like he's
like the unique kind of bipolar that
changes really fast so he was absolutely
nuts
what's my Pole would mean that he's an
angry one minute and happy another hmm
or depressed or in anger yeah mm-hmm
what was he doing for a living at that
time um he was working at a bakery he
worked for the Morita bread factory in
Orlando and then he also worked for East
bought the the factory that would make
the buns for McDonald's no [ __ ] mm-hmm
old-school human dude yep what does he
do now now I don't do [ __ ] he's retired
you still talk to mm-hmm you tight with
I mean I still fight with him he likes
to fight so I fight with him you call
him to trailer
sometimes he calls me to try to try to
rev me up yeah she can't take yes she
could
that's what we do it's Cupid then you
push the unlovable oh stop being a Cuban
dad it stopped being a dad is it yeah it
stopped he is love [ __ ] to consider
especially now with everything that's
happened the last couple years you have
to adjust I think there's always been no
way to raise your daughter and the girls
I grew up with a lot of the girls I grew
up with their parents did a good job I'm
looking at these girls and I'm thinking
back about going to the house as a kid
and just being friends with them nothing
sexual going to their basement and
partying and how their dads were how
their parents were I try to mimic their
actions because their daughters came out
listen to our rocket scientist right but
the hell out there [ __ ] sucking
twenty dicks on beanpole upside down
singing daddy issues they're all married
they have kids but a lot of times you
can't control some of the [ __ ] that
happens to your kids oh well you know
what I mean like my parents tried to
forget my dad was super strict and I
still ended up getting molested he
couldn't [ __ ] change that because he
didn't know what's happening from the
inside of the family you know what I
mean there's some [ __ ] that you just you
can as much as stricter as whatever that
you want to try to do sometimes you
can't you can't be there all the time
you know so that's what you should just
also have a good commute like
communication like if I would have been
comfortable if I wasn't have been scared
of my dad I would have been able to talk
to about some [ __ ] that happened to me
you know but I didn't feel safe at home
either because he was always so strict
and so insane so I was like you I think
you'd have to be able to do both you
know talk to my daughter
I told my wife Tim she had until she was
five and then after five mm-hmm I gotta
take it down a long road because that's
what we do you have to push your
daughter a little bit just so she sees
absolutely
and I write everyday for her I read a
journal furnace or something that Mister
me she knows who the [ __ ] I am she is
doctor here at secondhand or anything
like that just I wanted to be a piece as
a woman you know that's I think I made a
lot of women in my business put on a
piece and it's chasing it for peace and
then they get married have a kid and
that goes the career after one does
understand there's no more whatever the
[ __ ] they would yeah I don't know just
there's so many different reasons why
people do stand-ups we're back to the
mental health issue that was scary when
I got into comedy like how many people
were there with mental health issues but
you didn't have the balls to tell him I
would look at them and smile and say god
bless him dead before the grace of God
go I let them think whatever they want
to think there was water to Seattle in
particular that was a man that she
became a woman and she was the ugliest
thing you ever saw in your life like no
effort oh my god if you saw her hands
you could tell she was a man and they
were big creepy hands sure but nails out
and looked like this [ __ ] animal when
she was 4 foot 8 and she would wear
heels
and she would wear a wig and she would
put makeup on they had done the whole
thing when our jokes was they cut my
dick off and having a jar at the house
there was mental health issues running
there like the government at that time
she had more opiates than anybody well
yeah why she had purses filled the pills
like you know and she kind of liked that
she had diabetes something they told us
not to drink and she kept drinking but a
head was too big like what she was a
head was too big yeah because when
you're a man you become a woman
something happens I don't know oh and
they start taking like the hormones yeah
I had got really big so it's all her
balance off oh wow so this time she'd be
walking the she'd for like a Betty Boop
she just fall over she go on stage at
dance clubs and dance and have a couple
drinks on her and a balance of God
you'd fallen ahead that's what she
finally died up she landed on a [ __ ]
coconut window Coleman Ono died the kid
Jeff shouldn't a drink at a
Margaritaville why would you drink in a
place with coconuts I don't know I
didn't ask her she just went ahead and
[ __ ] went into a coma and then
[ __ ] uh
the kid that used to put the handcuff on
Jeff whatever his [ __ ] name is he
hung himself I worked with one of those
lunatics from Seattle he used to do this
fit at the end where he would he would
do a strip dance and end up in a thong
did you ever work with that guy and he
was like we work together in Milwaukee
Wisconsin and the comedy club in the
basement of a strip club and he would go
up there and he would he kept telling
everybody that he was sober but then he
would go and get [ __ ] and then I
would have to take care of him and I
didn't [ __ ] know that guy I just met
him but the club's like all right here
you go
is this club still open I know I mean it
was just a London I'm like a
money-laundering
comedy club it wasn't like a legit they
didn't give a [ __ ] about the show all
their money was being made upstairs
it wasn't Milwaukee mm-hmm Milwaukee's
always had like the weird scene mm-hmm
the comedy club wasn't but that comic
was from Seattle economy that you know
was it yeah yeah I don't know I left
Seattle 20 years ago so god knows what
the [ __ ] is going on out there now I'll
tell you his name after the podcast I'm
pretty sure you know who is it's funny
that I just bumped into one of the guys
from Seattle when I was in Portland
David crow [ __ ] great guy grace honey
yeah David crows no [ __ ] joke yeah
and it was weird because I always think
of those guys that didn't make the move
down here that really could have been
stars like David crawl if you would have
came down he would have nails he still
makes a ton of money just behind frets
yeah yeah yeah he does a great job opens
yeah he's happy yes farm the whole
[ __ ] deal I think he's got a formula
no there's another guy that I always
think about roundball a black dude he's
older from fifth
he's six he's got to be 66 mm-hmm 65 64
he always made me [ __ ] laugh and he
took care of me too up there it's just
weird the people that you've done 13
[ __ ] years of calmly yeah I know how
long have you been that way for uh in
April it'll be three years three years
so you moved out here at the 10-year
mark yep
10 years 10 grand and young agent the
whole thing um I actually just started
talking with Andy from Broce team okay
that's good good man yeah yes mm-hmm
I called me yesterday cuz that's his
favorite restaurant oh really
yeah Peter belugas his favorite
restaurant so I called him I said guess
where I'll be tomorrow at 3:45 12:45 you
at time [ __ ] Pete now he should feel
living like a [ __ ] doctor in there so
yeah he was like god damn it when I
couldn't get in
it's funny I have this audition next
week somebody called me and they're like
yeah we want you to read for this role
or whatever and I got the role and I am
you know I did what I usually do it I
read it and then I read it twice and
they light-yellow it out mm-hmm but the
yellow magic marker and then after that
I [ __ ] in read it stoned a couple
times and I start making notes and then
right before I start getting into the
middle of things I go into my little
have a notebook just for acting over the
years has just forgotten so slow for
years I would go through a notebook or
two a year or just auditions who the
casting director was I can't keep a log
of all that all that Wow really yeah see
were you going to who gets Christmas
cards at the end of the year
uh-huh you know I would make sure they
all got thank-you cards after the
audition you know it's it's mean I never
got to do it it's boring [ __ ] yeah but
if you don't do it you're gonna regret
it and it's good to see what your
numbers are at the end of the year and
where you are and how many callbacks you
got I said
I used to call those no those notebooks
they call back notebooks mm-hmm
because all I wanted was a Corvette
that's all I'm looking for
I wasn't even looking the book so when I
started this program it was called the
callback and then the second year the
product the project was called the
second callback third year the project
was called Bukit yeah and every year
after year was called Bukit so I would
have the notebook in there and the first
page would just be all the dates the
caste leader Act and all that stuff and
then once you open the notebook
I would leave another page blank and
then everything after that which eat was
each audition in the page so let's say I
was reading for Donnie Brasco sure I
would say Donnie Brasco 217 2001 and I
would put the name of the character
Sonny black and then I will put the
casting director underneath and then I
would read the sides and break the
character down if his name was Leo I
would call him Leo Durocher
give him a back name and I would write
what the character was who he was how he
got into the mob what crime family who
was wife was I would just write this
fake biography about this guy and I
would have something to work with and
then I would take the scenes and look
all cut the scenes and how many scenes
like for this audition I have a Monday
mm-hmm I feel get cut to two scenes so I
would look at the scene and dissect the
scenes what's really happening in the
first scene and what's really happening
in the second say yeah what happens like
right before then afterward in 2001 we
couldn't make rent rent for $700 and me
and my wife couldn't make rent my wife
put away money and got me a birthday
present and it was to go to UCLA to go
to a Ludi GMO casting session right and
it was called this the subject is
casting and in my hand right now I'm
still holding the original paperwork
that it says and when I read this
I took this and I combined it with the
principles of the Comedy Store mm-hmm
and I started booking like a [ __ ]
machine really do you understand me like
at that point at this point I had done
like maybe 70 auditions I had auditioned
for The Sopranos an audition for Rona
kress at audition for some big names and
I would get callbacks and get nervous as
[ __ ] and this this besides was shaken
when I was reading at the callbacks and
stuff but once I read this I have made
myself read this before I really should
so as I'm preparing I would read this
and I would make notes in the audition
to where I would have to and how would
have to make choices and this is what it
says says the subject the casting and
listen to how I come compares to stand
up this is a subject of casting Luigi
amo helpful tips concerning auditions
just like a joke make strong acting
choices that means in the joke is to
stand behind your joke don't say that Jo
like a [ __ ] if you're gonna say it's
saying at all passion either have it or
go home
anything goes commitment to preparation
commitment to your choices in the room a
star has to be dangerous and
unpredictable the big sell is selling
you to you persistence you are unique
perseverance listen acting as a career
not a job rejections should be plate
pleasant not an excuse to leave the
business one yes makes up for fifty
knows at least Charles Durning for
eleven years had no acting jobs hang in
there you win the part in the moment
make that moment that [ __ ] kills me
that's when I [ __ ] start I know
exactly what he's talking about
yeah did you see it when actors do it in
their work two reasons for the auditions
to get their job
there's no first reason but the real
reason is to be remembered you can't be
a defeatist in the world otherwise don't
go don't audition stay home give the
audition up and burn it burn the [ __ ]
room
it says prepare prepare prepare it can't
be done and you can do it if you want a
part go after it a beautiful model came
and wasn't good at all that good excited
bubbly fresh but not that good the next
day she went she sent me a letter I
thought I better look at her a tape
again she made me think twice so do
something anything but do something
don't give up you always have a choice
even when you lose if you lose losing
the blaze of glory instead of losing to
passivity make strong choices you may
influence someone for the next time
somehow you have to take a risk you have
to light a firecracker on the ass and do
something that seems to be totally
off-the-wall for the character what you
stand up yeah that's it mm-hmm
listen to those words again totally
off-the-wall to light a firecracker on
the ass and do something that seems
totally off-the-wall for the character
the [ __ ] ball is in your court but
you don't know it you think you're a
[ __ ] victim and you're scared and
you're afraid casting directors have a
problem and they're calling you to come
and solve it just like when you have a
plumbing problem you call a plumber you
have an acting problem you call an actor
the actor has to come and do it and when
you solve it the casting people are
happy so come in with your version it
goes like this
my ideas my reading I hope you like them
you don't okay next time shake it up
don't settle in some way be furious
acting without risk challenge and
conflict is not worth doing an artist
and is a rebel and unpredictable the
audition space is yours the time is
yours don't waste it don't come in with
a chip on your shoulder get rid of your
hostile attitude focus it's all about
focus give yourself a license for
imagination that [ __ ] destroys me
mm-hmm a license for imagination that's
why I tell my daughter constantly only
blow me draw yeah we [ __ ] color and
I tell her what differences in May
there's no Lee you know I go off on it
she gets it now and I'll improve that so
much that they has to be in the
animation project they see what she turn
really oh that's awesome
the job is yours until you lose it
that's such a better way yeah it's a
better we didn't think about it acting
is a lifetime journey and act as a
magician he transports us to another
time in place
he makes us believe he's someone else
while we're watching we forget about
ourselves or not concerned this is this
little worksheet
like I said his [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
because I always go through it and it
makes me a [ __ ] Savage
yeah just basically just telling you to
be confident in your choices and take
risks and there's nights even before I
go down to the comedy store but I will
take this out and read it and yeah like
five the [ __ ] up yeah so what I get down
look at this it's like a good mantra
this still has me writing down agents to
send emails to packages
Nancy after daniel hart see how at aqua
this is [ __ ] old [ __ ] here my friend
coz but that's what people don't
understand that is done the same way
every time
like i don't miss a step not because I
invented this because of what they tell
you their steps to this yes steps all
along the way you know and uh they're
not gonna be easy
they're not gonna be easy and that's why
I applaud the [ __ ] out of you because
you just feel this friend you're in the
[ __ ] you rent the lion's den you're a
door girl at the Lions neck that means
any of those what happened and they kill
the girl last week there's a lion kill a
[ __ ] girl ass was gonna case they
didn't kill me though no no
zoo or something others or something
[ __ ] poor girl thought she was a
veterinary assistant why just [ __ ]
either you're a [ __ ] dog girl at that
you know hmm so you think you got an
education by watching those other comics
absolutely I think that I think I
learned I think because I used to go
even before I worked there when I moved
to Los Angeles I would still come in I
would come and watch because I think
that's another thing that's lost is a
lot of times comics don't watch each
other anymore
I totally say I had to make a night one
night well he just goes to watch calmly
and to take a date so he has to sit
there and he has to feel like that
person to make you a better comic I want
you have to go on it's like I went on a
date to see Doug Stanhope my girlfriend
at the time
mm-hmm and there was so much such a
shocking experience I cancelled my gig
the next day and thought about quitting
comedy because I got to see inside the
you know you have to see don't sit in
the front row that's too much pressure
no no no yep this like in the third role
watch a comedy show as a pedestrian now
that you've been doing it for a year and
a half and see what they feel like while
you're on stage and you get it's gonna
scare you that's when you see the animal
from within that's when you've you know
in your finger in it and you open up a
Clinton look in there that's what you
see there's like a missing part you like
I don't know if I want to she's missing
it's like five inches I can't do it
would you stop with the clip click now
with you fifty and it hangs between your
legs in my paws and you can't do doggy
style because it looks like an oxygen
mask like a guy gets under it they could
just pull over his head it looks like a
[ __ ] jellyfish oh no not there
I swear to God I stated check then we
did doggy style the curtains it was like
the gay guy pulled the stick and the
curtains would just drop I was younger
and I like that she was hot and [ __ ] but
that should turn me off but the wings
you can see that you can see the
curtains from the back the curtains
would fall and they had like if she
moved they would move they were so long
Oh like it's like Dumbo ha ha and she
was sexy but the wings were better than
me no it was just like a couple inches
longer like a little penis and they cut
it out in the hospital but so women's
wings are tight like the [ __ ] is playing
hangs on it's got a crazy glue
yeah the back flap is just dropped but I
didn't know it to you the doggy style by
that time we were dating a while who
cares I'm saying
well you can't I mean you're still gonna
come well gives a [ __ ] yeah she's got
hey you can't you know I don't know I
don't come look at me look at my face
I'm no [ __ ] Vito's matter Ali I gotta
take what they given you know knowing
that you're not Vito's matter Ali makes
a big difference in your life for sure
as guys that walk around thinking
they're [ __ ] you know any darkness
nothing happens and then they think
their recorders broken I had some
buddies I just worked with somebody like
that they told me they hadn't I watched
him eat a big dick on stage and then
afterwards they said they hadn't bombed
in 10 years they told me that they
hadn't bombed in 10 years do you realize
how delusional you have to be to not
think you bombed in 10 years
cuz you did I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are I don't give a [ __ ] if you will are
Dave Chappelle you didn't you have
bombed within 10 years I was living to
Seattle apartment I had a bed mattress
on the floor I was living with a guy
named mark Madison he's still around he
was in San Diego he does come here from
time to time we all friends me and all
of us for friends
that a house we rent this from nothing
it was like two years being condemned
the crack house there were mice
arrangement it just wasn't a happy house
you know he did all the cooking in there
and no no no he did all the cooking in
there and uh and he did all that [ __ ] in
there
mark Master how they were cooking
nothing or anything but I still remember
sitting on my [ __ ] milk crate
I got a milk crate in my room that I
would sit on to write jokes and the
phone was right there mmm I'm getting a
call from that child that delusional guy
telling me if I had five minutes to talk
to him like oh what's going on he goes
they hired me as a headliner on Tuesday
and then I got demoted to a feature then
Thursday the guy said I was half the
host I don't know what to do should I
quit happened how heartbroken it was
that as bad of a situation I was I was
featuring was that a good feature at the
time ah right you didn't say I had 18
minutes if I had him if I caught a good
wave improvising
I'd go 26 25 yeah but this poor bass had
been demoted to a host from a headliner
from a headliner because like I said he
banged the older women and they paid for
all his to see those as [ __ ] and he his
[ __ ] packaging was beautiful he had
head shots for all the characters he
thought he was yeah like he hadn't
dressed a white don't Scarface or
machineguns him as Pacino hems De Niro
and his Jackman he couldn't do any one
of their voices at all he was and I saw
me the bag of dicks like three times
that bomb but just like ya know nothing
[Music]
I talked to a mutual friend of ours I
was asking have you ever heard from him
and he goes nah how he lost his mind
only guys I started comedy with and em
there's a couple of there was one good
good guy I was friends with and he tried
to kill himself
so every time I would see him I'd hug
them and whisper in his ear I'm checking
you for weapons and he would giggle and
we were good friends and eventually he
shot himself mm-hmm
couple years ago his name was PJ more
God rest his soul it's so weird how when
you're at that level of oppa my curry
50% of it is mental house putting
anybody down at all I'm just telling you
a reality if you think about it if
you're an open Michael right now you're
living the life next time you go to the
big city open mic look around look at
the people that are around you and
listen god bless them I'm not putting
anybody down for trying Tommy
but at that level is a lot of just crazy
people the store yeah it's the mics open
that means anybody Sunday there's no
process it used to be I mean boom
chakalaka turned out not to kill anybody
yeah but years ago I thought boom
chakalaka sometimes he dresses up like a
man
sometime he dresses up like a woman he's
got HIV you know that and he would bring
his buddies with him now he comes alone
boom chakalaka always brought a bunny
with him with something he always had
hound to show you sweetheart of a guy
mm-hmm I love when I see him now I just
laughed at how that all the survivors
yeah boom chakalaka is still around all
the people would talk [ __ ] I can't see
myself doing this and it's great it's
just crazy that they think they're
killing like I'm just I'm just thinking
about the ones that I've seen there's a
level on the road of comics that are
very disgruntled alcoholism runs deep
drug dealing you know drug use I was one
of those guys you know you don't get to
work in a room every week you don't get
to open up for David Allen Joe Rogan
every week you got to go up there these
rooms that are C rooms and open up for
guys that at one time had a dream yeah
and they're angry now they're angry you
as soon as you mention our way
oh boy do you get a [ __ ] ear beat away
for a while ELISA yeah everybody does
nothing for you I'm the funniest guy I
could be I could talk anybody I could
[ __ ] didn't get a standing ovation every
night The Improv and nobody would care
for me nobody can follow me there was a
kid that every time I saw him that was a
story
nobody could follow me dog nobody could
follow he's gone he couldn't follow
myself mr. nobley to follow well people
will hire me to go on the road but then
they fire me because they can't follow
me really that's what happened yeah
that's what happened they're making
[ __ ] two hundred thousand a night and
they find you because they can't follow
you okay keep telling yourself that
yeah those I went through all that [ __ ]
so that's why I don't listen to it I
know just by doing it you just know
mm-hmm you could look at somebody and
see them different things that they tell
you that they're young talent oh yeah
and if I see it
other people gonna see it so you don't
want those people to really see you
until you're [ __ ] really [ __ ]
throwing that's why I tell them not to
come out here don't come out here until
you have your [ __ ] together if you don't
know who the [ __ ] you are you don't have
your voice don't [ __ ] come here and
figure it out because first of all
there's not a lot of time for you to
figure it out and second of all it's
gonna drive you insane trying to start a
comedy that Club closed one in Orlando
it was like four years I think four
years so I only had be in see rooms to
learn how to be a comedian it was all
[ __ ] VFW's and like Holiday Inn
lounges in [ __ ] coffee shops and
again like seafood restaurants where
they didn't know comedy was happening
just some promoter convinced a guy to
give him 400 bucks to do a show yeah I
can't imagine I go up there with that
[ __ ] that microphone is [ __ ] good
evening how you doing place is over here
or wiping their mouth you know how you
doing I don't know if you guys know
where we do a little comedy night here
where we have great comedians that you
show NBC CBS HBO these guys haven't been
seen on public access and you're up
there lying to their face is the [ __ ]
and then there's the white people really
get excited like oh my god it's oh oh
the first guy goes up there starts
talking about abortion you kick the
aborted child or what unborn baby he ran
over his mother's head and these people
are sitting there going what [ __ ] just
trying to eat my [ __ ] tilapia why is
it what am I getting it's verbally
assault oh my god awesome you see the
[ __ ] the restaurant manager run and
go it's time to stop talking about
abortion see I'm saying like it oh my
god those rooms are hell nobody looks at
you you leave dead defeated like you
leave there with your 30 bucks and you
want to rip up the 30 bucks like I don't
wanna tell you want to put in my car cuz
my cars on the blow up on the drive home
there used to be a Mexican restaurant
and Denver I used to just go down a bomb
mm-hmm and it was typical because
there's a 40 minute ride so it was a
long ride home El Torito and they gave
you a dinner and you got a $25 gift
certificate oh wow back in those days so
dog when things are bad yeah what do you
wanna drive grateful about that we don't
get the worst Mexican food that's fun
that food is so bad they had one on
Burbank Boulevard mm-hmm right by The
Tonight Show and they knocked it down oh
really
across the street from NBC it was the
last oh no I think the one Huntington
Beach is still open it was supposed to
be at the house of margaritas I took my
wife there we both will find sick
for three days we got the appetizers
during the happy hour you [ __ ] blood for
three [ __ ] days it was terrible well
calm and I'm happy that you're out here
and you found your voice and I'm happier
the second door woman thank you Comedy
Store history Mitzi Shores looking down
you're going on
I hope so I hope she's not just mad that
there's a broad here you know I get
pissed off when I hear stupidity and I
used to hero out of it
Bourbons of it and it was like throwing
at me like I would take offense for it
like all the time you store doesn't bad
little one but you know look at the
lineups every night there's only two
[ __ ] women you know but here's the
other thing nobody takes in
consideration is a lot of Toni times
those women are already working you know
it also has to be based on who's
available like I can't tell you how many
times I get asked to do the same show to
do slike three different shows on the
same night you know and there's only so
many places I can be but you get to come
this door first
well yeah without question what I'm
saying is that they always for years the
last like two or three years I've heard
that there's been lawsuits and [ __ ]
women have complained there's not enough
spots at the store well guess what not
only did I save all the jokes I did all
the auditions I want I've also I also I
have every night that I went up to
lineup from 1997 you wrote every time
you've got the story I stole the page
did you really yeah so I got a tree
lined up I was on so people could see I
was a real killer 20 years from now when
I do my booking mm-hmm you see some of
the early lioness where I went up I got
some really lineups that's awesome I
have a notebook at the bottom of a
drawer that is four inches thick and
it's every call sheet
I have ever gotten with the mini script
oh yeah cuz you book a job you get a
call sheet which is your name with a
number mm-hmm that shows you what seems
you're in you're in the scene 8283 B I
saved all my call sheets it's just
[ __ ] thick it's too yellow manila
envelopes and it's got like everything
there's one that's every audition I went
on like I look at it and I get tears in
my eyes
Oh like the auditions that were not like
how
Will Smith in black yeah I want to go
out for [ __ ] like that I was not ready
for it at all I walk into a room with
these seasoned actors and I would lose
mm-hmm I would lose from the start you
know I got we're going and go [ __ ] I'm
defeated and then one day I started
thinking like wait a second [ __ ] these
[ __ ] they never bombed in Buffalo
that was my rough is bombing ever yeah
the 2001-2002
mm-hmm the roughest bombing I ever had
was where I do the best now today no yet
Buffalo yeah like that's the first time
I went home well of course if it hurts
you the most you're gonna dominate it
[Laughter]
you have accomplishments every 90 days
and you're a comedian but you also have
setbacks it's a it's a rough thing to
say that's a rough thing to understand
you also have little setbacks every
couple of days it's rough to make you
wait for those 90 days for something
good to happen yeah yeah but it's one of
those bombings that stays with you
like prolong touch to have specific
bombings
mm-hmm Buffalo was all those places that
was to the bone yeah it hurt you like I
was already a regular at the store I was
doing shows around town I wasn't
supposed to be bothered like in my mind
I'm not supposed to be bombed well I did
and [ __ ] it was it was mind boggling
when I went to my hotel was a condo that
of course the condo mm-hmm and I just
wanted that [ __ ] room and I was
disgusted I was like man I don't know I
should just how is in Buffalo see you so
you finally you did so bad you deserve
the condo it's so bad I told you staying
in Jersey like not even coming back that
I live here now we got any dates coming
up um yes I do
what should nervous date my nearest day
coming up is going
I'm gonna be headlining Cobbs on March 6
okay yeah just you all yeah that's a big
[ __ ] rule I've never been there it's
my first time alone and I'll be at the
Throckmorton day before the fifth okay
the Throckmorton in and the sixth at
Cobbs in San Francisco you know we have
mining time when you Maria get um I
don't know I don't have anything on you
just quality whenever she's ready she
she's actually my landlord it's you
really yeah that's a good way don't just
tell you don't I don't but I saw that
you are going to San Antonio in a few
weeks oh yeah yeah that's it
why'd you take me to San Antonio I'll
cover the right he wasn't my landlord he
just a bit he was just a promoter and I
would go bill you gotta let me 400 bucks
they would lend it to me and I would
just work it out with gage for the month
oh you like three $50 gauges of $1.00
gate mm-hmm he would tell me forget
about the rest don't worry about boom he
is a good guy so that's why sometimes
[ __ ] rolls downhill sometimes generosity
rolls downhill
yeah it's both the bottom of the hill to
catch it catch it and dodge it well
still thinking the generosity listen man
I'm happy you took the time to be on the
show I see you are you kidding I'm
honored thank you for having me you're
very free you're very loose onstage
you're gonna go someplace not maybe
today maybe tomorrow maybe six years but
they gonna be giving you a show one day
I could see it yeah I hope so
wait can they find you have a web page
for sure Carmen Morales calm for all of
your carmen Morales needs I also have a
podcast called no sir I don't like it if
anybody here likes things likes
disliking things it's at no sir pod you
could follow me on all the assorted
social media at the funny Carmen I just
want to make a public apology to you
right about two weeks ago three weeks
ago oh it's you
yeah at the store Apple was I was so
proud of her going up we passed each
other in the main room and you know I
want people to understand this
even at the 20 year mark when I'm at the
store I'm still floating on clouds
mm-hmm so when I'm walking past you and
I cut you back it's like telling you I
love you without saying it yeah like I'm
being dragged
I gotta dodge this guy I got to do this
I gotta get to the original I mean you
bumped into each other now you put such
a smile on my face that night I looked
at you then he got a Comedy Store shirt
on and she had a jacket on but she had
Jessica Pennington with you yeah Jessica
willing to Wellington anything whatever
I [ __ ] know these peoples mix what I
might at top it off I didn't want him
bearish Society I was trying to tell her
to close her jacket because I didn't
want anybody to know she was a door
woman I wanted her to respect her as a
comic and she took it like I was talking
about the tits no I was like I don't
have another shirt you were like you
should change your shirt and I was like
I don't have another shirt and you're
like we'll just take your shirt off
they'll love if you have your tits out
to put your button up your shirt on top
of it I'd rather you have cleavage all
right I have a Comedy Store sure enough
gotcha
I'd rather you take your shirt off
button your jacket we have a button pop
like a little [ __ ] list malfunction
everybody forgot about the Jenny I
rather you have a tick malfunction in
the main room and get 2,000 more Twitter
followers back [ __ ] I calmly stir [ __ ]
out and they look at you as a door purse
right so I was just trying to give you
the respect that he deserves as a
comedian nevermind a woman just a
comedian right so that was funny that I
was like no just take your shirt off for
[ __ ] button I'd rather you have you
know saying yeah boria's the NEM see
time I did I did three I didn't
hat-trick that night yeah I saw that the
next day you did the belly room the
original room and the manual and I just
did a like two weeks ago I just did four
I did four sets in the same night -
belly room a main room in an original
Ramon the same night home we do a
connoisseur the Improv in the Laugh
Factory that sounds fun there you go
wait I like him when it's ruinin they're
back to back like that Monday's used to
be Latino night and freaky Monday at the
improv
both of them are hot if you get on one
of them you jerk off all over yourself
really
and there was one time where I got that
that's why I ran to the store please
please I will give you three minutes BAM
triple Ana once you get the triple how
do you feel you talk [ __ ] with you
[Laughter]
didn't talk to me for a couple days yeah
after three at door I'm like you gotta
go up and finish up hours I'm like that
yeah like couple weeks ago I was leaving
and my wife had cooked something and I
told the baby I would be homeless don't
other something I haven't got ain't
o'clock set and as I'm walking out the
door
[ __ ] the great talent coordinator
Adam comes up to me goes hey man do you
want to open up for sure pal the
original at 11 o'clock know what you
said no I got my you know I'm saying I
got all this how these [ __ ] people
don't know you're a dad we do yeah I'm
just saying like you having a hard time
like like Trent we were talking about
like transitioning from like character
wise like you are a father and like
talking about it and and then people not
like really getting into it with you yet
hope that dose of man is what the death
it's hot Thank You Tori thank you oh
look it's still [ __ ] ready to do bong
hits you in Southern California amazing
good there do bong hits and give you a
wife establish one of those what's the
surprise I'm [ __ ] Janice what were
you saying I'm sorry to interrupt what
just that uh like you're you gave like
you gave up opportunities like that to
do something that would be considered
really cool and calming it'll be with
your family like you know what I mean
there is a difference you are growing
and changing too and I think that I
think that your audience or people in
the audience that know you and are
familiar with you have to grow and
change with you you know because you are
you are a dad yeah but these people are
50 or 25 years old these people I come
to the shows of kids so they can't be
dads yet
I don't want them to be dead I want them
to sling dicta you have to do that made
a mistake at 27 and got married the
mistake really was a mistake because I
ended up doing comedy out of it I lost a
daughter I have a twenty seven-year-old
daughter
we don't speak we have no communication
but if you look at the big picture
it took me 25 years to come up with this
it's a not an excuse it's a way for me
to put the pain away sure I gave up a
life for a life before that I didn't
have a life I didn't have an identity I
was just an ex-felon that did coke and
whatever I got oh I got the life I
wanted I got the [ __ ] wife the kid
the calmly we got the podcast with we
I'm not in jail I'm healthy I got the
life I wanted but I had to give up a
life worth and I can't determine at that
you know was I am I good yeah to become
a really to become up a good anything
there's got to be sacrifice to become
literally a doctor pre-med you know
pre-law law you know this time you gotta
give up [ __ ] because we can't best thing
about comedy is you can't you don't have
to go to weddings that's the greatest
thing about comm I get a gig you look at
your booty like I looked at your web
page you know have a data my web my
wetsuit daddy's hand got cut off by an
alligator he won't be able to type the
December so nobody knows it's an
authorized secret gig dog body that's a
great thing about being a I haven't
updated my website have you ever said
the town that they were having the
wedding in book we're having our wedding
in Santa together
I keep it quiet and I do the wedding
keep it think I'm gonna get marry a San
Antonio I got a gig in Rio de Janeiro
that's aren't even gonna [ __ ] cross
there's no way my planes even going over
your point I actually can't advertise it
performing forever I'm performing for a
drug lord so I can't really put it up on
the Internet
don't say nothing cuz I want to live
another day I leave my head on [ __ ]
YouTube on the stick mix of this boys do
bad I just I can't even be having this
conversation with you go don't go my
best wishes for your wedding yeah don't
[ __ ] go to wedding use this [ __ ]
right there
anyway karma Morales thank you for
taking the time don't forget to see it
up March 6 up in our neighborhood
updating cobs with the [ __ ] savages
[ __ ] last time we went up there we
tortured some guy with a dog Renly yeah
you and butch did the night before I got
there but you didn't do that you know I
remember I came in for Saturday you did
Friday you showed me the videos though
what'd you do
that's a great club we went to 7-Eleven
Oh some guy yelled at us in the corner
and we just yelled back and forth for a
few [ __ ] hour he followed you and
then you followed him to come over and
eat that [ __ ]
and he would walk come back and yell
some beggars you ain't gonna touch me no
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
I need that [ __ ] done oh my god we
taped it and we died four [ __ ] hours
I guess you had to be there anyway karma
Morales March 6
you [ __ ] brain prime Thursday
next week a week from today the 24th to
the 26
get ready to rock us me and my man
George Perez and what's a little Indian
dog guy from the store and son says I
sign Ahmad a son Ahmad I like that name
inside our mind is opening up
we're gonna have a good time it's a
trifecta of colors and Mexican Cuban on
side I'll back the [ __ ] so whatever you
are there's a joke for you there
whatever the [ __ ] you are there's a joke
there
I might hire a transvestite DJ I'm not
I'm not sure you know I gotta find one
who still spins old school buddies Asian
looking for transgender DJ must be able
to spin Oh school let's see what happens
I'm saying get the ad busted out on
Twitter you anyway I love you
[ __ ] I see you Monday morning
whether you rock I want to thank Carmen
Morales where can we find you Carmen
Morales calm at the funny Carmen on all
the assorted social media and I want to
thank the [ __ ] and I want to
thank you [ __ ] for being loyal
family from wookie spooky to Bob Lowe
Lingus to Jay bish to dante [ __ ]
buzina I haven't heard from you Dante
but don't send me no more letters all
right you killing me [ __ ] I love
you guys stay black have a great week
I want to thank Carmen Morales I want to
thank the Christ kill and I want to
thank you [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank my bookie
you know why cuz that's the way to go at
my bookie you play you win you get paid
I mean let's face it the NFL playoffs
are here you don't want to be that guy
with no rooting interest as your
relatives and friends sitting around
watching the game not this year not for
the 53rd Super Bowl and it's around the
corner and you got the Pro Bowl and you
got the playoffs and you got caught you
got a thousand things a thousand angles
how to make some Gita's it really is the
most wonderful time of the year so make
sure you're ready for the daily action
by signing up at my bookie today they
pay fast when you win ownership really
cares about good customer service and
they offer you the craziest props where
you bet is as important as who you
betting on and if you want to make money
during the bowl season and so on and so
forth you got to go to my bookie
I trust them but if you have to take my
word for it check about yourself all
right join now and my bookie wall for
you a 50% deposit bonus to make sure you
have a nice bankroll football season use
promo code Church when you deposit the
activation
often that means you put in a yard
singing a buck-and-a-half or I lose
better than my bookie use promo code
Church why because if my bookie you play
you win and you get paid also on it the
best the good
alpha brain shrimp check the protein
powders - how far the shroom tech immune
the shrimp export they all deliver and
this is what you're looking forward to
get the year started in the right
direction I can't get you 10% off in the
kettlebells and the club bells and that
stuff but as far as supplements are
concerned I got your back go to alikom
right now and this is something when
you're looking to get get and I was the
way out and the box press in church BAM
and get 10% off your order delivery
right the house you can't beat that this
is how Joey takes care you he's got my
booking for you he's got on it for your
head and for your help and don't forget
next week I'm at the brain improv
Thursday night to sadly my man Jorge
Perez we're gonna rock that [ __ ]
so make sure you're there and that's it
not that I'll see you Monday morning
nice and early ready to [ __ ] rock
I don't want those stories you
understand me I have a great week and I
love you guys thank you for supporting
the church every weekend kick this
[ __ ] muley